hundreds of people crowd onto a colonial
era suspension bridge over the Machu
river in Western India the cables appear
to be straining under their weight
in the aftermath survivors swim to the
walkway now dangling in the water
boats searched in the darkness swimmers
trying to find those who hadn't surfaced
ambulances raced from the riverbank
burying survivors to local hospitals
among the victims a large number of
children
many children were enjoying holidays for
Diwali and they came here as tourists
all of them fell one on top of another
the bridge collapsed due to overloading
as the new day dawned the extent of the
disaster became clear the 230 meter
bridge now just Twisted cables hanging
across the river
rescue efforts continued but this was
the search for bodies not survivors
and questions about why a bridge that
had been closed for renovations for six
months and only reopened last week was
clearly not safe
a case has been filed on the agency
which was overlooking the building and
maintenance of the bridge under sections
304 308 and 114 of the code of criminal
procedure
local hospitals are treating survivors
but the death toll is rising too in what
is one of India's worst accidents of the
past decade
and painful memories even for those who
manage to escape
my two young daughters wife
sister-in-law my wife's aunt and her
three sons were on the bridge while the
rest of them crossed the bridge my wife
and her aunt remained there when the
bridge suddenly collapsed and they fell
onto the river
recovery boots pick through the thick
Reeds floating on the river more than
400 people were thought to be on the
narrow bridge when it collapsed Tony
Chang Al Jazeera